I don't know how many of you are old enough to
remember Sarah Palin. Sarah Palin used to be
the governor of Wasilla, Alaska. She was John
McCain's presidential running mate in 2008.
Had John McCain won. Sarah Palin would have
been a heartbeat away from the presidency,
which is a very scary thought because she is
aggressively incompetent but could have been.
Maybe I don't even think it's even close. Would
have been dramatically less competent than even
someone like a Dan Quayle. So we really
dodged a bullet in terms of Sarah Palin
not becoming the vice president of the United
States. Sarah Palin recently said she will get
a COVID vaccine over her dead body, meaning
she will die before she gets a COVID vaccine.
Sarah Palin now has COVID, and it is, of course,
raising a lot of questions as to whether what
the course of the disease is going to be. Reuters
reporting Sarah Palin's positive COVID test delays
her New York Times defamation trial, which is also
just hilarious. Sarah Palin has tested positive
for the virus, forcing a U.S. judge to delay
her defamation trial against the New York Times.
It's particularly funny that her bogus defamation
trial now gets delayed because she has COVID. Jury
selection was expected to start Monday, pushed
back 10 days after the test results for the 57
year old. Palin became known she was expected to
testify in person as soon as today Tuesday. U.S.
District Judge Jed Rakoff in Manhattan said she
is of course unvaccinated since she has apparently
tested positive three times. I'm going to assume
she is positive. Palin also tested positive last
March. She has been. She is subjected to mandatory
vaccinations. It will be over my dead body that I
will have to get a shot. Here is the video of
Sarah Palin explaining that to Turning Point
USA is Charlie Kirk. Remember this?
Speaker 2: And I will. It'll be
over my dead body that I'll have to
Unidentified: get a shot. I will not be.
Speaker 1: My crowd loves that.
Speaker 2: I want to do it, and
they better not touch my kids either,
because that's that's where the well,
governor, some people say, though I might lose
my job, I might get kicked out of school. Yeah,
I know and you know, I think if enough of us,
though, rise up and say new enough is enough.
There are more of us than there are of them. OK.
Speaker 1: Anyway, so over her dead body, she
will get vaccinated. Let's really hope it doesn't
come to that. Now there's a question as to whether
she's really unvaccinated or is claiming she has
to keep up appearances. Some people even saying
I will, I will have to get a shot over
my dead body, which may be different than
I've gotten a shot by choice, but I won't get
one by force with all these people. It's like
the DeSantis thing where you boosted, sir.
Well, you know, I got the normal shot. Well,
so hold on. Are you boosted or not? Oh, no, I'm
not going to say that. Now we could ask her. But
the truth is that should really be between
her and her doctor. Because as you all know,
all of these Republicans believe that medical
decisions should be left to women and their
doctors when it comes to women's health. Those
are private matters in which the state should have
what? Oh oh, I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I now I
understand why it's so stupid to be saying that.
So Sarah Palin has COVID and she I guess
we'll get a shot only over her dead body.